today I'm going to take a look at a pure
mathematics exam from University now
pure mathematics deals with mathematics
setters more abstract and concepts
rather than applied that doesn't mean
that pure mathematics doesn't have
applications but it means you're dealing
with things like the theory behind
numbers and functions and the abstract
nature of pure mathematics makes it
quite difficult I will say that I took
pure mathematics throughout my physics
education not only because I did a
double major in math but because it is
useful for physics now the exam I have
here is a real exam that would be taken
I think your second or third year of
university study that's undergrad it
would take you three hours to complete
and in this booklet there are eight
questions four of them deal with real
analysis and four of them deal with
complex analysis the difference is that
complex analysis deals with thinking
about the theory behind functions in the
complex plane so we've got a bunch of I
the square root of negative one I've got
a bunch of eyes and you're working this
particular exam paper I have is from the
University of Manchester because they
uploaded all of their exams for the
public to see so shout out to them and
let's have a look at it even though
there are eight questions in this exam
you're only going to have to answer five
of them so it wants you to pick two
questions from real analysis to
questions from complex analysis and then
the last question you choose to do is
going to be up to you because of that
this exam is really quite long so it
will take you much longer than three
hours if you were going to try and
attempt all of the questions
so let's look at the first section which
is the real analysis section so real
analysis deals with the properties of
real numbers and functions you want to
understand the theory behind mathematics
and ideas like sequences convergence
limits continuity and smoothness so the
first question we have is a question
about limits you're asked to find
essentially or show that the limit of a
certain function is a certain number or
a certain limit and you do that with
various techniques I won't go into
exactly the details of how you would do
it but using the epsilon-delta
definition you want to show the limit so
essentially you just want to take X to
be really really close to a certain
value and see what the entire function
essentially is bounded by what the limit
is next we have the intermediate value
theorem now the intermediate value
theorem talks about if you have two
points connected by a continuous curve
you can actually draw what we're working
with here
you've got an axes you've got a point a
and you've got a point B if that's a
continuous curve and you've got say a
certain line you've got one point below
the line and one point above the line
then at least one place on the curve is
going to cross that line
so essentially you need to cross a
certain line to get from point A to
point B that's what this theorem is
talking about and then you're asked to
prove some things kind of
to it question part 2 down here is
talking about what's probably quite a
familiar idea in calculus assume that a
function f is differentiable on a
certain range a B with a local maximum
at C prove that the derivative of the
function at Point C is 0 so really
you're proving that if a function has a
local maximum that the derivative at
that point is 0 and that's an idea that
underpins a lot of calculus and
optimization problems but you're not
often asked to prove it we've got
another question here that kind of deals
with calculus ideas we've got being
asked for a proof of the product rule
for differentiation and a few other
things about differentiation functions
and limits our last question in the real
analysis section as this one here I
probably won't go into this one very
much you can look at the kind of
language that these questions use it's
quite abstract and I when I took this
for my own real analysis course it was
definitely my least favorite math course
and it's because there's so much new
language involved that it's just really
hard to talk about or to think about
well that's what I found it's really
hard to describe to other people as well
so when I was always complaining about
real analysis I didn't quite know how to
tell people what it was about it's the
fury of mathematics essentially but yeah
it's it's also very hard to Google
questions like this because there are so
many symbols not a lot of language
moving on to Section B this is the
complex analysis stuff now I actually
really like complex analysis in
comparison to real analysis because
complex analysis seems to have
more applications complex analysis I
have actually seen used in physics and
thermodynamics and fluid mechanics and
essentially like I said before we're
extending the real functions like
Exponential's logarithms trigonometry
into the complex domain and range so
we've now got functions that can be
separated into real and complex parts
this first question deals with something
called the cauchy-riemann theorem and
essentially it's a set of partial
derivatives that can be used to test if
a function is complex differentiable
that means that the derivative exists
it's also called Hoo morphic as if that
is true these questions deal with being
asked to show that certain functions are
holomorphic and why proofs surrounding
that really number two in the complex
analysis part this is dealing with
mainly definitions of trig functions in
the complex plane so you can see the
definition of sine there using complex
numbers and it can also you can see it's
being used with a definition that
includes hyperbolic sine and cosine so
some of these definitions of trig
functions you might not have seen before
if you haven't done much work in the
complex plane
these questions are actually I think the
most straightforward in this exam paper
but they still look pretty alien if
you're not used to definitions like this
now we're getting into my favorite part
of complex analysis and why I like it
it's because there are some really cool
applications to integrals using complex
Nellis
and they don't sort of strike you as
being obvious but once you start to
learn about them I think they're pretty
cool so essentially here we have this
big crazy figure and what we're doing is
taking integrals around certain paths
now usually or often I guess certain
integrals are quite hard to do normally
but there's this thing that you learn
about in complex analysis where you can
take an integral that's usually quite
difficult to do you can describe it as a
function take that function and transfer
it into the complex plane do some crazy
maths with things like the residue
theorem Koshi theorem work out the
integral in that complex domain and then
convert it back into the real space
where you end up with the answer that
you wanted all along and the last one is
a similar vein this is using residue
theorem which again allows you to carry
out integrations in the complex space
that otherwise would have been quite
difficult just in real space I have
included this entire exam in the
description so you can have a good read
of it there I know it's probably quite
hard to see the details here so have a
look
I haven't provided solutions that's
because this is actually a real exam
from the University of Manchester
website but hopefully that gave you a
good insight into what some pure
mathematics looks like at university
this by no means is the most advanced
you're going to do like I said this is
probably second to third-year work it
might not necessarily be combined into
one paper I personally did courses where
real and hours and complex analysis were
separated into two different courses but
yes sick into third-year levels probably
about right there is definitely more
advanced work than this
hope it didn't scare you off thanks for
watching